the oppa taco Keely Alicia
MOG nahi pho hey everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my West world episode 8
video obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen it yet but is probably my
favorite episode of the season so far
like this great story about the ghost
nation person that we've been seeing all
the ways since those flashbacks to 30
plus years ago we got a little more
context for how Maeve's abilities work
in a teaser for like the very gruesome
future healing the man in black that his
daughter has planned for him like oh my
way is gonna be so much worse for him so
we had a whole bunch of stuff to look
forward to but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes we still have a
couple left to go but top 10 WTF and
Easter eggs starting with number 10 the
man in black crawls his way to the river
and comes upon the ghost or the ghost
finds him because he's awake there's
this implication that he's been watching
all this happen so he's probably been
keeping tabs on a lot of different
people because they implied that the
group of people that he's been traveling
with has been growing and growing as
more and more hosts start to become
awake so it's almost like he controls
the entire ghost nation and they're all
trying to help people and through that
he probably knows exactly what's going
on with Dolores and altered LOC people
they go into this grande flashback as he
starts telling his backstory to Maeve's
daughter and you get that first teaser
for what he was doing before the first
big narrative change so they don't give
a real clear explainer about when this
is happening when he goes from being
just like this normal happy-go-lucky
peaceful ghost nation soldier to like
the really hardcore killer that they
turned him into later in the episode
when he first gets himself killed so
that he can infiltrate the Mesa they say
it's been about 10 years so I think we
can assume he's been like this for a
little over 10 years but it is funny to
see his slow descent as he starts to
carve the maze and everything in all the
other ghost nation people think that
he's completely lost his mind number 9
that first uprising that he witnessed
because of the Death Bringer killing the
creator I love the way that they refer
to Dolores is the Death Bringer if you
ever wondered if she was a villain this
season if it wasn't clear before it's
definitely clear now we need to find the
door before the Death Bringer ends us
as if Dolores is probably going to wind
up killing most of the other hosts it
makes you think about all those host
bodies in the lake that we saw at the
end of episode 1 which I'll refer to
later in the video because that's also
very relevant when he says that he can't
find the door out anymore even though he
goes back to the location where he saw
it before looks very similar to the
artificial lake that we saw at the
beginning of the season so just remember
that number 8 he finds a logan post
naked ride like he rode for so long that
the horse died from exhaustion and he
looks like he's had heatstroke
maybe his dehydration but he's almost
speaking in tongues and it sounds a
little bit like prophecy to the ghost
whose real name is actually a Quecha
like he says this is the wrong world
there's got to be a door out of here and
that gives him the idea to you know
number seven find the valley beyond
which is the first time that he sees it
there's a giant hole you see a ring you
see all these containers that look like
they're storing things like potential
bodies for people that they're trying to
duplicate there's still a lot of big
questions about the grand Delos plan
like are they doing straight-up
futureworld plot where they're trying to
replace world leaders and take over the
world that way is it this really evil
plan
or are they simply just trying to profit
by selling a form of immortality to
these really rich guests
whatever that is this is the location
they call it the valley beyond that
we've been referring to all season long
but then number six once he learns
what's going on he goes back and awakes
his wife up is this beautiful reunion
I loved all their scenes together the
actress that played his wife was great
obviously the actor that was playing the
ghost was amazing you may actually
remember him from a couple of other
notable series I believe he was the
sheriff on the reservation during a
Longmire that was the most recent thing
that I've seen him in but he's great in
all the stuff that he does but the whole
thing is is that after they have that
reunion and she remembers him when they
go back to the valley beyond you can
still see the construction site but it
looks like they just covered it up so
you have to imagine that there's this
great underground facility that's
storing all this stuff but if you look
at the rock formations it looks similar
to what we saw when Bernard was looking
at this artificial lake but that makes
you wonder about all these dead hosts
that are floating in the lake if they're
actually dead like when Bernard says I
killed them at the end of the season if
maybe somehow they found a way to enter
the door or maybe they died trying to
enter the door and only a couple of them
made it through but we don't know that
this moment right here where he's
staring at all of them is the actual end
of the season it's probably right before
the end of the season there's probably
like a lot of narrative that happens
after this moment but number five he
figures out that he needs to do the same
thing that Maeve did during season one
get himself killed
so that he can infiltrate the Mesa and
get more answers they pull him in we get
this really convenient date it's been
ten years since we've updated him you
know ten years since he became the
killer looking version of the ghost
nation warrior the scene where he finds
his wife by traveling down into the
bowels where they store all the bodies
that they fridge it was totally
beautiful and it's this Great Awakening
that he has so if it wasn't clear when
he says that he was like fully awakened
to what his true purpose needed to be
when he says he looked beyond himself it
was him just realizing that all the
other hosts or most of the other hosts
were going through a version of what he
was going through so he sort of became
this Moses character that wanted to lead
his people out of Egypt so to speak like
this probably good metaphor let my
people go like he wants to lead them
through the door purely out of
benevolence so become sort of like a
really good version of what Dolores is
trying to do
Dolores wants to get out of the part two
but now she is quote-unquote the Death
Bringer so it's sort of two sides of the
same coin light and dark
everybody wants out of the park some
people want to do it for selfless
reasons some people want to do it for
selfish reasons and remember the door
that we keep referring to has two sides
to it so you travel out of the park
through the door but I also think it's a
bit of a metaphor for where the man and
black is headed where his arc is going
to end we'll talk about that again in a
second but all this idea of being
selfless brings us back to Sizemore's
storyline number four crying over
Maeve's body so it's a little bit funny
to see him like this but it's also
really touching because it's sort of him
coming full circle like you deserve all
the things that you want you deserve
your daughter you deserve to be happy
and he sort of goes on his way I kind of
thought that he was gonna try and rescue
Maeve but then we got an explainer at
the end of the episode for why she's
still sitting on that table because we
need to learn that
could communicate through her daughter
and other host so there's a little bit
of exposition that was required before I
think an inevitable Sizemore rescue
scene so like she's all splayed open on
the table there like she could probably
save herself but I think that what
they're implying here is that that
Sizemore is eventually gonna realize
that they're just gonna hack her to
pieces and use her for their own
purposes so he needs to protect her and
help her escape so maybe Sizemore winds
up killing some of the guards to protect
Maeve but number three the ghost meeting
Ford this is such a great scene too and
I love the way that he just rolled up on
what looked like this elaborate diorama
like it could have been Ford just
tinkering with some sort of attack setup
like he wanted to create this new
narrative so that's why he's doing this
but you never really know with Ford like
he could have just been doing this is an
elaborate invitation to come talk to him
like Here I am you know come ask me all
the questions that you want to ask me he
explains everything to him and lets him
know what the timeline is so this is all
happening right before at the end of
season one you will know when the Death
Bringer comes for me again to lead your
people to the door
but again just reminding you that
Dolores is the Death Bringer she's going
to end us all I love the way he talks to
me his daughter like yeah I'm gonna
protect you I couldn't protect you that
one time they keep referring to the man
in black who's still sort of like
bleeding out over by the tree this whole
time but number two when Williams
daughter comes for him this actually
gives you a bit of an idea because they
keep talking about the door the way out
and then when the ghost is talking to
the man of black earlier in the episode
he also said the death is the way out
and you don't deserve the way out yet so
when Williams daughter says that he's a
burden that only I can bear and they
both want to heal him so that he can
suffer like live with the knowledge of
what he's done she says that the way
that she's going to do that is going to
be much much worse like she's trying to
appeal to the ghost nation warrior like
no no no I'll make him suffer even more
would it not be crazy if she did the
same thing to him that William did to
James delos trapping a version of his
consciousness in this lost bunker
situation that would be like a living
hell for the man in black like he'd be
aware of what he done he sort of gained
the sense of morality but because it be
a digital space
he would live forever effectively and
this whole thing has been about the
guests trying to turn themselves into
versions of the host Dolores said that
in last week's episode you're trying to
become us so what if they're all going
for the door in the valley beyond the
hosts try to escape the big twist for
William when you know like the little
Ford host told him at the beginning this
new game is for you the game that
William has been playing has been the
road to what Ford has been doing this
whole season like existing as a digital
consciousness so there are obviously a
lot of big questions about where they
would take that because they blew the
backups up like they can't store
information like that anymore
but it just depends on what the
mechanics of the valley beyond are which
they haven't fully explained yet number
one of course was that last big
explainer for how Maeve is connected
deeply to her daughter into other hosts
in the park mostly her daughter though
they want to turn the metaphor into a
literal thing take my heart with you
like she has a deep permalink to her
daughter but it's not just a
metaphorical emotional connection that
like real humans you know have deep
connections to their offspring Maeve has
a physical connection to her daughter so
she can actually see through her eyes
which they kind of did with that last
scene where you're looking at the ghosts
eyes and he says will protect your
daughter
if you survive come find us if not have
a good death like I said I think you
know part of this Sizemore Redemption
arc is helping to save her so I don't
think that this is the end of Maeve
story by a long shot but I should also
say you know one of my number one you
know sort of tied for number one was
their use of Nirvana heart-shaped box
that cover we found they put it in the
trailer away at the beginning of the
season but now it makes a lot more sense
because of the saying that the ghost
would say to his wife take my heart with
you so I just love the way they weave
that into the actual way they wrote the
episode what I'm expecting is is that
because there's only two episodes left
next week will be sort of an explainer
for what's going on with the valley
beyond and how it works and then the
finale will leave us with a really big
cliffhanger pushing us into season 3 so
e3 is happening right now there'll be a
couple of things that I'll probably do
for that in the next day or two so just
look out for that and then just leave
all your questions and video requests in
the comments below
but click here for all my other
Westworld videos and click here for
brand new Avengers thank you so much for
watching everybody
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]